so suppose we have a point mass particle
of mass M moving with a velocity vector
V we can introduce a quantity we call
the momentum of that particle I'll label
it with the symbol P and it's equal to
the product of the mass times the
velocity this is something you've
undoubtedly seen before now let's think
about the dimensions of a mentum for a
moment so dimensionally momentum has
units of mass times the velocity and so
that's in SI units the units of mass are
kilograms and then the units of velocity
are meters per second you can also
express momentum dimensionally as the
product of a force times time and so
again in SI units units a force or the
Newton and the units of time is the
second okay so these are the SI units
from a meant of two different ways of
writing the same the same dimensions now
we've seen that for a single particle
we can write Newton's second law as the
force is equal to the mass times the
acceleration or equivalently we can
write that as the mass times the time
derivative of the acceleration DV DT now
if M is a constant then I can rewrite
this as F is equal to the time
derivative of mass times velocity or
equivalently as the time derivative of
momentum since MV is just equal to P
okay so I actually want to such as I'm
not you're gonna put it in a box because
it's very important that I can write
Newton's second law instead of F equals
MA as F equals the time derivative of
the momentum and this is absolutely
where we'll see the momentum becomes
very useful because it turns out that
this form of Newton's second law is
actually the most general form of the
equation because it's applicable not
just to a single point mass but also to
a more complicated system a system
consisting of many masses or system
where the mass is changing or remasters
flowing as in a fluid in all of those
cases this form of Newton's second law
is correct F equals MA which is probably
more familiar to you is actually a
special case of this law for the case of
a single point mass so this is where
we'll see the momentum is quite a useful
concept especially as we start
considering more complicated systems as
well as we'll get you a little later in
the course what I'd like to do now
though is to take a closer look at this
equation force is equal to the time
derivative of the momentum whenever we
have a relation involving a derivative
like this we can always also rewrite it
in an equivalent integral form which can
be very useful and give us a different
way of looking at the same information
so let's take a look at that
so if I take this equation and integrate
both sides with respect to time then I
can write that as the integral of F with
respect to time is equal to the integral
of the right hand side D P DT with
respect to time and let's make this a
definite integral
I'll go from time t1 to time t2 on both
sides here
now this right-hand side is just so the
integral of DP DT with respect to time
is just P at time 2 minus P at time 1
and that is just the change in the
momentum vector going from time one to
time two now this integral on the left
hand side we give a special name we call
this the impulse this named impulse
calls to mind a short sharp shock of
some sort but it can also refer to a
weak force acting over a long interval
and notice here the function f the force
F is in general a function of time they
said this doesn't necessarily mean a
constant F this can mean a force that's
varying in time and what this equation
tells us is that the change in the
momentum of the system doesn't depend on
the detailed time dependence of F but
rather just on the integral of F and so
suppose I were to graph the force as a
function of time going from time zero to
a time delta T and suppose I had some
complicated function that looked like
that
the impulse is just the area under this
curve it's the integral of this function
that's the impulse and the change in the
momentum depends only on the area under
this curve and not on the detailed shape
of the curve so what that means is that
I can define an average force by
choosing a constant force that has the
same area as this example on the left so
suppose I calculated that and there's
some constant force here I'll call this
F average going over the same time
interval the average force is that
constant force which has the same area
as the area under my F of T so in other
words F average times delta T which is
the area on the right hand side here is
equal to the integral of F of T DT
integrated from zero to delta T okay
which is the area under this right hand
curve and so my average force is just
that integral F of T DT divided by delta
T and this is integrated from zero to
delta T so that's my average force